[Música]
muchas gracias
la foto de esta niña que ven aquí
fue compartir la estela de anar visto
conmovió a millones de personas en todo
el mundo la niña había sido
supuestamente separada de su madre al
ingresar a la frontera entre méxico y
eeuu sin embargo días después se supo
que la niña nunca había sido separada de
su madre la imagen era engañosa ya que
había sido utilizada por varios medios
de comunicación super prestigiosos para
hablar de la política 'tolerancia cero'
migratoria
donald trump en este caso vemos un muro
que supuestamente divide la frontera
entre méxico y guatemala una foto
compartida
lladó en el año 2016
con una leyenda que dice si los
mexicanos pueden proteger su frontera de
los guatemaltecos porque nosotros en
eeuu
no podemos proteger nuestra frontera con
el supuesto muro que quiere construir
donald trump el problema es que esta
foto era falsa esta foto fue tomada en
realidad es una foto que corresponde a
la valla que divide israel y egipto
estas fotos estás imágenes forman parte
de lo que hoy en día se conoce con el
término fake news un término que está de
moda y que muchos políticos y
celebridades utilizan para responder
sobre
realmente verdad es que les resultan
incómodas nosotros los periodistas
preferimos el término desinformación y
llamamos fake news a todos esos
contenidos que se hacen virales en las
redes sociales y que tienen el objetivo
claro y explícito de manipular a la
gente a gente como ustedes a todos
nosotros ahora una de las preguntas que
siempre nos hacen a los que verificamos
contenidos es decir a los que
funcionamos en esta especie de árbitros
y este mundo de mentiras es quien hace
eso quién está detrás de esta fábrica de
mentiras y por qué por qué cuál es la
razón las razones son varias en muchos
casos lo hacen por humor para burlarse
de nosotros para ver cómo y cuánto
caemos en otros casos y esto es el más
peligroso es para reforzar o extender
creencias religiosas sentimientos
nacionalistas
xenofóbicos para manipular a la gente en
los períodos electorales al consumidor
para generar miedo pánico usted
seguramente en uruguay a cada tanto a mí
me comparten la información con nuevos
tipos de violencia o nuevos tipos de
robo que incluso abajo dice la leyenda
comparte esto entre sus familiares
amigos o incluso niños que desaparecen
de las escuelas que muchas veces también
son falsos también lo hacen para generar
clics cuanto más clics más publicidad y
es decir más dinero pero también lo
hacen para desacreditar a los medios y
es ahí cuando varias organizaciones
entre ellos la mía la que hizo trabajo
decidimos que debíamos pasar a la acción
ya no podíamos quedarnos como antes de
brazos cruzados
un periodista siempre verificó datos
antes cuando nosotros nos encontrábamos
frente a una mentira lo que hacíamos era
ignorarla en un rumor lo dejábamos de
lado ahora realmente sentimos que
tenemos que informar también sobre lo
falso
hay un estudio del instituto tecnológico
de massachusetts que hice la que la
gente comparte muchísimo más las
noticias falsas que las verdaderas es
decir lo verdadero no puede competir
contra la falso y por eso sentimos que
debíamos actuar sobre todo cuando
sucedió el caos que generó las
elecciones en eeuu y el break sheet en
el reino unida entonces el comisiones
que lo implemente
es por sobre un tema otros e impresión
[Música]
facebook es un disco de gente
entonces
verifique juniors-arg office live black
edition
[Música]
vivo se arruine juanin including
cabalmente en halter state of tax a king
is always on line
[Música]
bastón de medias colapse en guaymas
fluyen confidentes
fucking interpretation tributos pero
peor y después
[Música]
pero claro esto lo que se llama la
verificación de contenidos no lo podemos
hacer solos si nosotros pusiéramos a
todos los periodistas colaboradores de
afp donde yo trabajo a verificar
contenidos no nos daría ni el tiempo ni
el alcance ante la cantidad de mentiras
que por segundo circulan en las redes es
por eso que las alianzas son claves por
eso es que a afp s en los últimos años
hemos decidido reunirnos con otros
sitios que también verifican contenidos
hay sitios incluso que solo se dedican
exclusivamente a ello en américa latina
por ejemplo la práctica creció tanto que
en 2014 había sólo tres sitios que
verificaban contenidos ahora son más de
18 incluso hay uno en uruguay ante las
elecciones ante cualquier proceso
electoral esto se hace mucho más agudo
es decir debemos reunirnos ya entre
medios y sitios así lo hicimos en las
elecciones brasileñas con comprobar en
crochet en las elecciones francesas y
verificados el año pasado en las
elecciones de mexico pero claro nada de
esto sería posible no lo podríamos hacer
si no involucramos también a las redes
sociales porque es ahí donde la gente
todos hoy en día
consumimos y compartimos información
por eso también las alianzas con
facebook whatsapp red y twitter también
son súper importantes obviamente con
youtube que pertenece a google que hace
facebook cuando se encuentra con o sea
nosotros verificamos para ellos y le
informamos que una información es falsa
lo primero que hace es reducir esa ese
contenido en un 80% y obviamente eso
baja
muchísimo su capacidad de monetizar lo a
ustedes a las personas que quieren
compartir noticias falsas facebook les
lanza una pequeña advertencia que dice
esta información fue verificada y la
decisión estaba en ustedes si lo quieren
compartir o no y lo mismo hace google
una de las preguntas que siempre siempre
nos hacen es pero cuál es el impacto de
las fight news de las mentiras políticas
sobre todo porque son las mentiras
políticas las que más se comparten en
las redes
y los estudios los pocos estudios que
hay que fueron después la lección de
eeuu lo que dicen es que en realidad el
alcance es gigantesco pero a la vez
superficial porque la gente comparte
noticias que generalmente reafirma sus
creencias entonces lo comparte con las
personas que les son afines este es un
ejemplo bastante claro y bastante
impresionante
esta foto fue compartida miles y miles
de veces en las redes sociales después
de la lección de méxico en julio en las
que ganó andrés manuel lópez obrador la
idea con esta foto lo que se quería
mostrar en especie de pánico
las ganas habló el izquierdista y la
gente va los o por marcados como si
estuviera ante una catástrofe lo que
llamó la atención es que los letreros
están escritos en japonés entonces no se
pregunta como una foto con letreros en
con japonés fue compartida tantas miles
de veces en un país de américa latina la
realidad en la imagen corresponde al
terremoto de japón de 2011 que provocó
miles y miles de fuerte muertos con eso
vemos que la gente realmente presta muy
poca atención a lo que comparten en este
caso vemos unos gráficos que muestran
que en eeuu en 2016 los que más
compartían y el crecimiento de las fake
news
dio entre las filas republicanas entre
las personas afines a donald trump
mientras que las filas demócratas las
personas afines a hillary clinton se
mantuvo bastante estable hace poco hace
una cuestión de tres semanas salió un
estudio de la universidad de princenton
que decía que la gente que más comparte
nos dice a falsas son las personas
mayores de 65 años esto es porque esas
personas
obviamente están estuvieron menos
expuestos a la era digital
el caso de brasil merece un capítulo
aparte porque fue brutal fue una guerra
descarnada entre las filas de bolsonaro
y dejada al punto que llegó un momento
que ya nadie sabía si bolsonaro había
sido realmente apuñalado sobre todo
porque después se mostraban fotos de
bolsonaro sonriendo después de la
puñalada en el caso de haddad se llevó a
decir que promovía la homosexualidad
entre los niños con un tuit educativo en
los centros escolares la la guerra en
brasil fue muchísimo más complicada
porque se libró en whatsapp whatsapp
tiene conversaciones cerradas
encriptadas
entonces claro verificar contenidos en
whatsapp es muchísimo más difícil y el
66 por ciento del electorado brasileño
se informó durante las elecciones en
whatsapp este caso fue bastante
impresionante porque es una foto que se
muestra a una supuesta simpatizante de
de cada uno del pp y a los que a la que
simpatizantes de bolsonaro le dibujaron
una esvástica
lo que es bastante emblemático que la
foto fue compartida por medios de
comunicación super prestigiosos en
brasil incluso periodistas amigos me la
compartieron como muestra de la
violencia descarnada que se estaba
viviendo en las elecciones brasileñas la
campaña de desinformación sigue en
brasil por ejemplo en este caso tenemos
a lula mirando la investidura de
bolsonaro desde la cárcel a principios
de enero la foto es un montaje y es un
montaje acá me reconozco varios
fotógrafos que cualquiera se da cuenta
que es un montaje de pésima calidad y
aún así fue compartida miles y miles de
veces
otro de los temas que a los fabricantes
de mentiras en las redes es uno de los
favoritos es el tema de la migración
américa latina vive en el año pasado una
ola emigratoria en varios frentes de un
lado tenemos a los centroamericanos
sobre todo de guatemala honduras y el
salvador que se dirigen hacia eeuu por
méxico
del otro lado son los venezolanos que
están viniendo hacia sudamérica y los
nicaragüenses que van hacia costa rica
esta ola migratoria desató una avalancha
una catarata de mentiras y generalmente
son todas anti inmigrantes como pasó en
europa como esta por ejemplo habitantes
venezolanos que ingresaron a roraima el
estado fronterizo con brasil y
supuestamente atacaron a los habitantes
del lugar
otro tema que les encanta a los que
fabrican face news es el tema de la
salud cáncer siempre sale algún alimento
que milagrosamente cura el cáncer y otro
que lo desarrolla todo sin ningún aval
científico esto es bastante
impresionante porque aquí vemos a [ __ ]
pig de papilla [ __ ] pib que es una
información que se compartió también
miles y miles de veces en todo el mundo
que decía que los niños que miraban [ __ ]
pig estaban más expuestos a desarrollar
autismo obviamente era falso
el papá es uno de los principales
blancos al igual que otras celebridades
quizás ustedes probablemente los
católicos reciban
cerca de las navidades una homilía muy
linda atribuye al papá que habla de la
familia y la importancia de la familia y
como debemos querernos y aceptarnos tal
cual somos la vida realmente maravillosa
el problema es que el papá nunca la dijo
también al papá se le atribuyó ante las
campañas de donald trump que apoyaba a
trump al punto que el vaticano tuvo que
salir a desmentirlo en este caso es una
información de que creía que quería
generar una biblia nueva o sea que lo
perdona que deja de instalar la biblia y
crear un libro nuevo y también se
demostró como falso
en este
mundo de mentiras verdades y verdades a
medias ustedes se preguntarán ahora
entonces en que creemos y por qué sobre
todo no deberían creer en nosotros que
visitamos contenido no sea quiénes somos
nosotros porque en este caso nosotros u
otros sitios
quién es dios quiénes funciona como
árbitro de la verdad y mentira por otro
lado también se le puede decir a un
medio de comunicación como el nuestro
unirse con facebook o con cualquier red
social no afecta de alguna manera la
independencia de ese medio
las respuestas merecen un capítulo
aparte
y quizás time para otra tez pero si les
puedo decir algunas cosas que tienen que
ver con esas respuestas en primer lugar
nosotros a mí me gusta mucho decir que
no es que desmentimos información
desmontamos información porque lleva y
esto es un proceso que lleva mucho
tiempo es decir tenemos la imagen y
vamos a la semilla de esa imagen de
dónde surgió lo mismo los textos o sea
hay todo un racconto es como que se va
desmenuzando todo el contenido de la
falsa información hasta llegar a la
conclusión final
la transparencia en es todo este proceso
es súper importante transparencia en el
procedimiento en la elección del tema
nosotros tenemos que de ser
transparentes porque elegimos verificar
algunas cosas y otras no en los fondos
que recibimos para verificar eso también
tiene que ver con la con la
independencia y la corrección otra de
las cosas que es súper importante es el
rigor no nos podemos equivocar
imagínense si nosotros estamos
verificando contenidos y nos equivocamos
ya nuestra credibilidad se perdería para
siempre entonces realmente tenemos un
equipo que se dedica exclusivamente y
minuciosamente a mirar cada detalle
obviamente hay todo un procedimiento de
fuentes etcétera ahora me gustaría
compartir con ustedes algunos consejos
básicos que también a nosotros los
periodistas nos han servido muchísimo
por ejemplo cuando nos encontramos una
imagen que tiene baja resolución dudar
no compartir cuando nos encontramos ante
un texto que tiene faltas de ortografía
también dudar cuando estamos también a
punto de compartir mirar los comentarios
porque muchas veces ahí se informa que
esa imagen fue tomada años antes y sobre
todo
antes de compartir
detenerse unos segundos y pensar es
realmente necesario compartir es una
responsabilidad es una responsabilidad
de todos nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]